مجلس الامن القومي والدفاع الاوكراني ان
الهجمات التي تستهدف موسكو بالمسيرات
نفذها من سماهم بالثوار الروس واكد عدم
وجود اي قيود على استخدام الاسلحه
الاوكرانيه المصنعه محليا ضد اهداف داخل
الاراضي الروسيا أياكم
لا يمكن ان تكون هناك قيود على استخدام
الاسلحه المصنعه محليا اتفق الجانب
الاوكراني مع الدول الشركه على عدم
استخدام اسلحتهم على اراضي روسيا هذا
ضروري حتى لا يتهم الشركاء بالتورط في
الحرب ومع ذلك هذا لا ينطبق على الاسلحه
المصنوعه في اوكرانيا لكن كما يقول الرئيس
الاوكراني دائما فان الحرب سوف تعود الى
الاراضي الروسيه كما نشاهد بشكل مستمر
الهجمات بالطائرات المسيره على موسكو
والتي ينفذها الثوار الروس على الاراضي
الروسيه